well it's now just past 1300 GMT and we
start in the Lithuanian Capital Vilnius
where NATO leaders are now wrapping up
their annual Summit the war in Ukraine
has dominated the talks with President
Vladimir zielinski making an appearance
there on the last day NATO Secretary
General Jen stoltenberg met the
Ukrainian leader and said that Kiev is
now closer to Nato than ever before but
he warned despite talks on Ukraine's
future membership of the military
Alliance the most urgent task was the
country's fight against Russian forces
program or practical assistance
establishing a new NATO Ukraine Council
and reaffirming that Ukraine will become
a member of NATO and removing the
requirement for the membership action
plan
our new
multi-air program of assistance for
Ukraine will help you transition from
Soviet era to Nato equipment and
standards I will make Ukraine's forces
fully interoperable with NATO
now despite frustrations around kiev's
membership talks Vladimir zielinski has
thanked NATO for all its help
we have come a long way in cooperation
with NATO and our soldiers have the most
fresh experience of cooperation with
various members of The Alliance the
skillful use of NATO weapons by our
soldiers has already proven that Global
democracy is stronger than any terrorist
threats against us
our diplomatic editor James Bayes joins
us now from the Lithuanian Capital
Vilnius James the alliance there seeming
to find some Unity after grappling with
some pretty tricky language it seems
tricky language and grappling also with
President zielinski as he always does
fighting very very hard to get
everything he can for his country
everything he can in terms of arms
ammunition but also politically trying
to get a seat at the NATO table as soon
as possible 24 hours ago he was saying
it's absurd they didn't come up with a
timeline for membership now he's being
much more diplomatic now he's with the
NATO allies and talking to them face to
face and knows really that there's
nothing else he's going to get at this
Summit but he's still making it clear
that he didn't get what he wanted in
terms of the language on membership a
point I put to one of those from one of
the NATO countries this is wapka
hochstra he is the Deputy Prime Minister
and foreign minister of the Netherlands
uh This truly is a historic Summit and
of course it is about two percent it is
about Sweden but it is also about our
tremendous commitment uh to Ukraine
um which I do think is
um being put on the table here today and
also we were continuing to articulate
that in the months and years going
forward he made the point that in your
other capacity as an EU foreign minister
the EU has helped Ukraine by giving it
candidacity status he said that would be
the same if if a membership was was
offered it would be a boost to the
people of Ukraine and it would be a
signal to Russia why not issue an
invitation he said that doesn't make you
a member of NATO well you know I think
none of us can can truly imagine what it
is like to send your own Sons and
Daughters uh to to the frontier to the
front line and knowing that many of them
won't make it back so that in that in
such a case you are you're always
looking for more you know I can actually
understand and appreciate and yet at the
same time
um you know our commitment is crystal
clear it is there for the long run and
we are articulating that once again
today and we're doing that
um through our commitments in in
continuing to deliver weapons and also
upgrading at the way in which we have
our conversations about future and my
sense is we're on the verge of also
committing uh to longer term security
commitments here today
president zielinski said membership
which you've said depends on the
conditions he said those conditions in
his view are when it's secure on our
land is that your understanding of what
the conditions are well you know
um in in my mind it is always a
combination of three things one is make
sure that Ukraine is successful on the
battlefield because if there don't any
other conversation about this topic
actually is useless the second one is
about security guarantees and the third
one is about nato in time we will arrive
at all three but if we do not manage to
sustain our efforts today tomorrow in
the in the many many long weeks and
months to come all else is actually a
futile it's not too many long months to
come until November 2024 I know it's a
U.S domestic election but a different
U.S leadership Donald Trump or another
Republican who is not so keen on the war
in Ukraine could that be a real problem
for this Alliance and for this support
of Ukraine and could you face an
Afghanistan type situation I'm much more
optimistic because uh in in my view both
Democrats and Republicans have
articulated their exceptionally strong
commitment to Nato also in in in in the
past number of years and and I do
believe that this will continue to be
NATO will continue to be the Cornerstone
of uh of our security and that is true
both for our friends in North America as
it is true for for everyone in Europe so
I am much more optimistic and I think we
need to be realistic about how much
longer the war might be going on and
that might well take us into another
couple of years
the Deputy Prime Minister and foreign
minister of the Netherlands speaking to
me a little earlier in an acting
capacity because of course last week at
the Dutch government collapsed what's
going on here now is the Summit is
winding up and what always happens on
this last moment of the summit last hour
or so is there's a series of news
conferences taking place because there
are the 31 NATO allies there's Sweden
also and invite T Nation that the rest
of NATO hopes will be a member very very
soon and there's Ukraine so 33 different
press conferences and statements to
reporters but we think we know the news
of the day and that is very much the
Ukraine came here asking for a lot it
didn't get everything it wanted what it
didn't get was the commitments on
membership the president zelensky wanted
and we'll be bringing you some of those
press conferences a selection of them
here live on Al Jazeera for now thank
you very much our diplomatic editor
James Bay is there for us in Vilnius
well meanwhile G7 nations are expected
to announce a plan that could give
Ukraine long-term security assurances
Russia says it's potentially very
dangerous for the West to provide
Ukraine security guarantees
um
we considered as a mistake and
potentially very dangerous because
providing any security guarantees to
Ukraine effectively ignores the
international principle of indivisible
security that said providing security
guarantees to Ukraine encroaches the
Russian Federation security this is
impossible this is fraud with very short
medium and long-term negative
consequences
let's get more of the view now from the
Russian Capital with Julia chapovalova
Julia short medium and long-term
negative consequences that sounds both
ominous and vague what does that
potentially mean in practice
well you know it's been officially said
many many times here that NATO is at war
with Russia the Russian authorities say
it's a a proxy war fought by the
Ukrainian proxy Army under the full NATO
control fulfilling their goals that NATO
is not a defensive but an aggressive
Alliance it's uh explained by the fact
that the NATO countries have never waged
Wars on their territory but only on the
territory of other countries the
possibility of Ukraine's accession to
Nato was one of Russia's red lines one
of the pretexts for the Unleashed back
in February 2022 Russia's special
military operation in Ukraine and NATO's
General stance as it's seen here now is
that none of the NATO countries are
willing to participate in a direct clash
with Russia and risk their army and
that's positive news for Russia of
course Russia is not happy about
turkey's decision to give the green
light to Sweden to join NATO Russia
promised to take retaliatory measures
but it remains to be seen which ones are
Russia says Ukraine's membership in the
alliance comes with obligations will
Ukraine be willing to participate in
potential conflict that NATO may get
involved in in the future Russia thinks
it's not the case on the one hand partly
Ukraine is a NATO they receive weapons
intelligence military training on the
other hand as Ukraine was not accepted
in the past for many reasons actually
not only because it had disputed
territories it was very corrupt but also
because NATO knew about Russia's
territorial claims they knew that the
Russian Ukrainian armed conflict was
inevitable and of course it didn't want
to get involved in a direct armed
confrontation with Russia under the
collective defense principle many of
those reasons still remain plus
Ukraine's membership is still unreal for
now because it will mean not only a
change in the geopolitical balance but
also Ukraine's entry into the Western
World which means that Ukraine will be
able to determine some of NATO's agenda
something not so many NATO countries
trees are ready for therefore Russia is
not very much concerned about Ukraine's
membership this time around there will
be a bigger problem if Ukraine stops
knocking on NATO's closed doors all the
time and begin creating new promising
military alliances between Ukraine and a
number of certain countries which will
be willing and interested in the
military corporation or maybe signing
direct bilateral treaties on Collective
defense Julia just separately a Russian
general who was at one point leading
operations in Ukraine Sergey sirivikin
he hasn't been seen in some time I know
he's always had a close relationship
with the Wagner Chief Evgeni pagosan do
we know where sirivikan is or how he is
yeah it's an interesting story actually
General is Sergey saravican Commando of
the airspace forces and Deputy head of
the general staff of the Russian army
has not appeared in public for two weeks
now since the Wagner group so called
Wagner group armed rebellion and nothing
is known about his whereabouts now on
July the 29th Russian and Western media
citing their sources reported that the
general could be detained or even
arrested and on the same day programmed
in buzzer Channel published a comment by
sura weekend's daughter who actually
said that nothing happened to her father
and the General's family right now
denies rumors of his attention or arrest
but serovicans appeal to the Wagner
Fighters which he recorded at the very
beginning of the pregosian Rebellion
Still Remains his last appearance in the
information field according to chairman
of this state Duma defense committee and
Drake cutsapol is now having some rest
and is not yet available well some
telegram channels also say that he can
be in North caucuses but actually none
of those reports have been officially
confirmed and of course we are waiting
for more information to come indeed
plenty of intrigue in the meantime
Julius
speaking to us there from Moscow thank
you